[Musique]
alors je vais vous proser proposer une
petite mise en
situation imaginez que vous avez accepté
d'accompagner votre ami à une soirée de
son
entreprise vous n'y connaissez personne
alors votre ami vous introduit à un
groupe de collègues voilà je vous
présente X il elle habite à
YZ ah génial et tu fais quoi dans la
vie catastrophe vous pensiez y échapper
mais la fameuse question tu fais quoi
dans la vie est arrivé à une vitesse
éclaire je vous parle de catastrophe
parce que moi cette question je la
Redoute à chaque fois pourquoi parce que
je suis incapable d'y répondre ou du
moins d'y répondre simplement et d'être
satisfaite par ces quelques mots qui
vont me résumer aux yeux des
gens je n'ai que 27 ans et pourtant
cette question on me l'a posé un nombre
incalculable de fois et plus on me la
pose moins je suis capable de donner une
réponse claire et qui me
satisfasse alors mais pourquoi j'arrive
pas à y répondre à cette question
quelque chose doit clocher chez moi car
les autres ont l'air de réaliser cet
exercice social avec une facilité et une
confiance qui me
déconcerte en préparant ce t talk je me
suis rendu compte en fait fait que je
faisais un lien direct entre ma capacité
à donner une bonne réponse à cette
question tu fais quoi dans la vie et le
fait d'avancer dans la vie car si je ne
suis pas capable de répondre à cette
question c'est que je suis perdu dans ma
vie et si je suis perdu dans ma vie
c'est que je n'avance pas et si je
n'avance pas c'est que je stagne voire
même que je
recule alors je me dis queil pourrait
être intéressant de Me penser sur la
façon dont je définis le fait d'avancer
dans la vie et je vais vous proposer de
d'y réfléchir vous-même quelques
instants comment définiriez-vous le fait
d'avancer dans la
vie alors pour ma part ça a longtemps
longtemps été synonyme de trois
points tout d'abord la réussite
professionnelle et scolaire en gros être
une élève brillante intégrer une
entreprise stable reconnu comme leader
dans un grand dans un secteur phare
d'avenir qui embauche et qui paye bien
d'évoluer rapidement au sein de cette
entreprise pour atteindre un niveau de
responsabilité ambitieux et conforme aux
études que j'aurais
faites ensuite avancer dans la vie pour
moi c'est aussi avoir un salaire
compatible avec un niveau élevé de
consommation en gros avoir l'argent pour
satisfaire toutes mes envies et mon
besoin d'avoir des env en
vie et enfin avancer dans la vie c'est
aussi pour moi le fait d'être convaincu
de ma de ma légitimité dans cette
réussite d'être convaincu que je la
mérite alors il se trouve que cette
définition est à la fois la source et
aussi le résultat d'une bonne partie de
mon parcours car j'ai toujours été la
bonne élève en effet à l'école je suis
comme un poisson dans l'eau euh les
notes la pression des notes me tire vers
le haut j'ai envie d'être première et je
suis première je passe mon bac haut la
main et j'intègre naturellement une
école prép une une classe préparatoire
scientifique alors je dois m'adapter
pour traverser ces deux années intense
d'apprentissage mais tout se passe bien
je réussis mes concours et j'intègre une
grande école
d'ingénieur en
image en surface l'image de la bonne
élève est
intacte en école d'ing les études sont
d'un très haut niveau et très utiles
pour qui sait ce qu'il a envie de faire
de sa vie mais moi je sors un peu de ma
bulle et je réalise que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je n'ai jamais eu à faire de
choix je n'ai jamais eu à me questionner
sur ce que je voulais devenir le champ
des possimes métait ouvert et me voilà
bien embarrassé de savoir ce que j'ai
envie d'apporter à la
société bon je me questionne mais je ne
sors pas sentier battu pour autant je
fais mes stages dans la gestion de
projet le conseil de la recherche et me
voilà diplômé de grande école
d'ingénieur le covid passe par là il
laisse entreapercevoir un grand
changement de
société mais il fait aussi ressortir
chez moi cette peur de ne pas assez bien
avancer cette peur de ne pas de ne de de
ne pas soigner mon cé alors pour ne pas
perdre de temps je vais intégrer une
grande une grande boîte de conseils à
Paris je me dis qu'il est possible de
changer l'entreprise de l'intérieur et
puis cette entreprise a eu le mérite de
miser sur moi de me prendre en sortie
d'école et c'était pas
gagné alors à ce stade là on peut se
dire bon bah ça va j'avance dans ma vie
et puis à la question tu fais quoi dans
la vie j'ai qu'à répondre je suis
consultante dans une grande boîte de
conseil en plus je pressends que c'est
un peu la bonne répse celle que les gens
attendent mais vous avez peut-être noté
que dans ma précédente définition je
conditionne le fait d'avancer dans la
vie au fait de me sentir légitime dans
cette réussite scolaire et professionnel
et ça c'est pas
gagné car dès l'école
d'ingénieur mon plaisir d'apprendre ma
curiosité naturelle souffre du fait
d'être encore et toujours jugé par des
notes et j'en viens à douter de ma
propre légitimité dans ces
études dans mon premier emploi c'est
pareil je suis malheureuse dès le
premier jour en fait je le savais que
j'allais être malheureuse mais je n'ai
pas voulu le croire je m'étais convaincu
que je pouvais encore être cette bonne
élève qui avance comme il
faut alors pendant 2 ans je vais
persévérer et je vais me questionner me
remettre en question en
permanence si je ne suis pas heureuse
dans mon travail c'est que je ne
travaille pas assez bien si je m'ennuie
c'est que je ne suis pas assez
proactive en plus euh en bonne élève
transparente j'ai j'ai alerté mon
entreprise dès le début mais on m'a
toujours répondu pas maintenant au nom
de ma montée en
compétence en fait j'ai fini par
vraiment avoir l'impression de ne pas
être entendu et d'être une sorte de
matière
exécutante
j'avais l'impression en fait de porter
un masque au quotidien et un jour un
matin ce masque je n'ai plus réussi à le
mettre j'ai fait un Bor out qui a
entraîné plusieurs mois d'arrêt de
travail à ce momentlà de ma vie je suis
complètement perdu mais qu'est-ce que je
vais faire de ma vie moi qui ai fait de
si belles études moi qui ai toutes ces
compétences et qui m'av pourtant
incapable de m'épanouir dans une
entreprise à quoi je
sers
je sens qu'il faut que je quitte cet
emploi mais je mets du temps car je mets
du temps à réaliser que le que c'est le
salaire qui est le dernier maillon qui
me lie à cette entreprise que je suis un
peu en train de mettre ma santé
mentale que je suis un peu en train de
de de de Diler entre ma santé mentale et
le fait de répondre à des besoins de
consommation
superflu et puis ma grand-mère Meur et
je réalise que la vie est courte et que
je suis en train de la gaspiller et je
démissionne
enfin je viens de traverser la fameuse
quête de sens en
entreprise alors en gros pour le dire
autrement quand on combine le syndrome
de l'imposteur et le syndrome de la
bonne élève ça donne un joyeux bazar et
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je
n'oserai pas me qualifier d'ingénieur ou
de consultante parce que je me sens trop
éloigné du schéma de l'employé
modèle pour complexifier encore un peu
le sujet il y a une autre facette en moi
qui est tout aussi constitutive de ce
que je suis c'est ma conscience
écologique alors je me suis demandé d'où
est venait cette conscience pchologique
cette sensibilité en fait elle a
toujours été là et elle a grandi avec
moi en parallèle j'ai toujours entendu
que la planète brûle mais que on regarde
ailleurs
que ma génération est dans le
pétrin alors ma sensibilité et mon
niveau d'engagement vont aller
crchendo ça commence à l'école par dire
à mes amis de ramasser leurs déchets par
terre ensuite en prépa je vais monter
une campagne de sensibilisation au
gaspillage de ma cantine gaspillage
alimentaire en école d'Inger c'est la
révélation ah mais en fait on est toute
une génération à être complètement par
l'urgence climatique et l'effondrement
de la
biodiversité ça rassure de savoir que je
ne suis pas seule et ça me donne encore
plus la force d'agir tout de suite
maintenant mais ça responsabilise aussi
car ça veut dire qu'il y a un vrai
changement de société en cours et qu'il
va bien falloir le
porter alors je m'investis intensément
en créant une une nouvelle association
dans mon école qui vise à traiter
l'écologie de façon ambitieuse et en
créant le pôle enseignement supérieur au
sein du collectif pour un réveil
écologique cet esprit écologique qui
fleurit en moi n'est pas une source de
tranquillité pour autant pourquoi moi
pourquoi je me sens responsable de
l'urgence climatique pourquoi est-ce que
j'ose
agir tout le tout ce qui m'entoure
devient le symbole des contradictions de
notre société et moi
comprise j'oscile entre insouciance et
hyperlucidité à un moment donné je ne
sais même tellement plus comment faire
que je je ne sais plus comment faire
pour me rendre utile me sentir utile et
avoir l'impression d'avoir un réel
impact que je finis par me
recroqueviller sur moi-même je vous
présente
l'échoanxiété bon alors si on revient à
notre situation euh à la question euh tu
fais quoi dans la vie je pourrais
répondre je suis une citoyenne et
coanxieuse mais pas sûr que ça
plaise bon en résumé je n'ai toujours
pas trouvé de réponse pleinement
satisfaisante à donner aux collègues de
mon ami mais pourquoi aucune de mes
pistes ne me
satisfait en fait je réalise que en
répondant à la question tu fais quoi
dans la vie c'est comme si j'allais
m'enfermer dans une case à tout jamais
alors que je suis bien plus qu'une
case mais alors pourquoi j'ai cette
impression en fait ça vient de ma propre
définition d'avancer dans la vie car je
réalise qu'un qurième point se cachait
derrière les trois
premiers ce 4ème point c'est le fait
qu'avancé dans la vie ne pouvait se
faire qu'autour d'une unique facette et
ça supposait un choix cornélien exclure
toutes mes facettes pour n'en garder
qu'une et exceller dans cette
voix alors je comprends mieux le conflit
intérieur qui m'habitait depuis de
nombreuses années avec cette définition
la dissonance que je ne savais pas
expliquer et ça fait sens car le fait de
choisir est un des exercices les plus
compliqués qu' soit pour l'homme en
effet on a tendance à ça suppose de
devoir oser dire non alors qu'on a
tendance dans notre instinct à préférer
le
oui
alors je me dis pourquoi pas changer de
définition d'avancer finalement pour ne
plus avoir à faire ce choix
conflictuel de trouver une définition
qui me permette d'accepter ma propre
complexité la diversité de mon parcours
la complémentarité de mes facettes et
même mes contradictions et mes
doutes alors pour moi maintenant avancer
dans la vie ce n'est plus avoir à
choisir une facette c'est au contraire
fusionner l'ensemble de mes deux mes
facettes et d'être pleinement consciente
et conscient confiante dans dans dans
dans ce que je
suis alors quelques remarques me
viennent à partir de cette définition
tout d'abord le fait
que des facettes que je pensais
incompatibles sont en fait au contraire
intrinsèquement
lié ensuite cette nouvelle définition
elle me rend plus forte elle me rend
plus résiliente car plutôt que de
m'amputer de partie de moi-même je
m'enrichis de toutes mes
facettes comme autant de racines dans un
arbre qui permettent de traverser la
tempête j'oserai même parler de
biodiversité
intérieure et enfin pour un esprit
contradictoire un esprit contradictoire
pourrait dire que l'absence de choix
n'est pas viable
mais au contraire avec cette définition
on fait à mon sens un choix très
puissant car en fusionnant toutes ces
facettes on crée on propose on devient
une sorte de version unique au monde de
soi-même riche et mouvante et je trouve
cette perspective excitante car à mon
sens les société la société et les
entreprises ont besoin de cette
diversité de parcours qui proposeront
autant de de d'approches différentes et
de chances de trouver un chemin viable
et en viable pour répondre aux enjeux de
notre
siècle bon alors concrètement ça veut
dire quoi fusionner ces facettes pour ma
part si j'essaie de d'allier mon côté
bon élève avec ma capacité à proposer un
nouveau récit écologique ça donne
ça j'ai réussi mes études parce que que
j'ai compris que mes efforts quotidiens
conditionneront mon avenir comme pour
l'urgence
climatique je ressens au plus profond de
moi les enjeux écologiques parce que ma
formation m'a permis de comprendre ces
enjeux et enfin j'agis parce que j'ai
acquis les capacités pour mettre en
place des projets et les
porter voilà tout est lié tout est
cohérent tout est plus
cohérent avec cette nouvelle définition
j'ai enfin l'impression d'avancer et
d'aller dans le bon sens je me sens
libre et capable d'explorer ce fameux
champ des possibilités pour y faire ma
place alors j'explore l'entrepreneuriat
je m'engage au niveau de mon territoire
mais je n'exclus pas pour autant la
possibilité d'un jour faire une thèse ou
de retourner dans une entreprise qui me
me plaira
vraiment alors maintenant quand on me
demande ce que tu ce que je fais dans la
vie j'accepte l'idée que ma réponse sera
en constante
évolution et je vais vous laisser sur
une dernière question et vous quelle
facette auriez-vous envie de réconcilier
en vous je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie